[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat quatre examens
nationaux un grand oral et du contrôle
continu c'est ainsi que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer entend moderniser cette vieille
institution qui à notre baccalauréat dès
la rentrée 2010 9 le togo le
gouvernement entend progressivement
installé un bac à la carte dans les
lycées généralistes et technologique
l'édition pourront ainsi choisir trois
puis deux disciplines en spécialité en
plus d'enfants commun composé de cette
discipline
ils devront bénéficier tout au long de
ces deux années de soutien pédagogique
et des dalles orientation ce premier bac
de réformer doit être inaugurée par les
élèves actuellement en place de 3e soit
en 2021
mais est-ce que les séries l s et es la
fin de ces séries là est ce une bonne
chose
ce nouveau bac améliora t-il actuel où
va-t-il créer une nouvelle usine à gaz
pour débattre de ces questions
j'accueille autour de moi bête respirons
débuté la république en marche des
yvelines est également delphine romani
co secrétaire du snes fsu des villes le
soir un peu tout est bien c'est d'avoir
accepté de débattre de cette question
alors aujourd'hui cette réforme
cristallise beaucoup de sentiments c'est
contraire d'une part et des personnes
qui disent que c'est l'avenir se prépare
notamment les personnes et les étudiants
les futurs étudiants à l'enseignement
supérieur et plus d'autres disant que ça
met à mal notamment la formation des
citoyens
pourquoi justement vous vous pensez que
c'est quelque chose de négatif d'avoir
cette ce bac à la carte aujourd'hui
alors déjà ce qu'on dit la première
chose c'est qu'évidemment le lycée il ya
des choses qui ne fonctionnent pas et
qu'il faut réformer avec eux la réforme
telle qu'elle est proposée
en réalité au lieu d'améliorer les
choses en particulier pour les élèves
les plus fragiles instaure par la
logique de parcours une logique de tri
sélectif en fait puisque le lycée
devient un indice est d'initier en fait
puisque pour le téléspectateur qui ne
s'est pas les élèves pour avoir un tronc
commun et puis ensuite une série
d'enseignements qui devront choisir et
que ce que nous pensons c'est que les
élèves qui ne possèdent pas les codes
qui ne sont pas épaulées par leur milieu
familial ou par leur culture la culture
dont il dispose de par leur
environnement ces élèves là vont être
mis en difficulté dans leur choix ce qui
va impacter non seulement leur réussite
dans le second degré mais aussi après la
poursuite d'études nommée supérieure et
pourtant ce n'est pas au rôle des
professeurs justement d'épaulé des
élèves et de les aider à l'orientation
d'autant plus qu'ici il y aura justement
une heure et demie d'orientation par
semaine alors effectivement baissé ses
idées mais ce que nous pensons c'est que
le fait actuellement d'avoir un lycée
qui est structuré en séries avec un
cadre qui restent communs à tous les
élèves qui ont choisi telle ou telle
série
c'est une manière d'encadrer
collectivement des choix de la jeunesse
de les guider et ensuite évidemment il
ya toute la question de l'orientation
qui est fait par les enseignants mais
qui est fait aussi une catégorie de
personnel qu'on appelle des psi n 1 les
psychologues de l'éducation nationale
des anciens co psy et que cette
catégorie de personnel dont c'est la
spécialité d'orienter les élèves et a
actuellement la mise en difficulté par
un certain nombre de projets de réforme
de l'orientation
trop de choix tue le choix et peut
brouiller justement l'avenir
professionnel
deux cdc en face voilà en particulier
pour ceux qui sont les moins initiés aux
arcanes du système éducatif est ce que
justement le bas va créer des inégalités
fragiliser les personnes les moins à
même de s'orienter dans non méandres des
106 depuis longtemps qu'aujourd'hui les
enfants ou même leur famille ne
choisissent pas les filières l es et s
en vue de leurs études ou ont vu leurs
capitaux grand coup en fonction de leurs
capacités mais simplement en fonction de
la réputation d'une filière aujourd'hui
on a plus de la moitié des élèves qui
souhaitent faire s non pas en lien avec
leur choix d'orientation professionnelle
mais simplement parce qu'on leur a dit
que c'était mieux qui vaut mieux faire s
aujourd'hui à des élèves qui sont mis en
difficulté justement parce qu'on les
envoie dans des sections qui ne leur
plaisent pas et qui correspond pas à
leurs attentes ou ou aux besoins de
leurs futures études supérieures donc
aujourd'hui on va être beaucoup plus à
l'écouté des élèves et puis on fait
confiance aussi vos élèves parce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas croire comme
quoi les les gens ne sont pas capable de
s'orienter sont pas capables de se
renseigner
donc les enfants donc s'ils auront leur
laisse un choix le choix qui sera
beaucoup plus vaste puisqu'il existe
donc on spécialité ils en choisissent
trois parmi les roses donc c'est à dire
qu'ils ont quand même largement le la
possibilité de douter et de sélectionner
plusieurs matières 6 hésite donc on ne
se formalise pas dès la première sur une
seule matière d'omd qu'ils ont quand
même toujours la possibilité de
d'hésiter et ils seront accompagnés
qu'on nous disait donc dans ce choix des
mêmes la place de seconde pour pouvoir
choisir leur orientation de façon
anticipée et pas comme c'était le cas
encore cette année au mois de janvier à
se poser la question qu'est ce que je
vais enregistrer qu'on veut pour mes
études supérieures alors qu'on a fait
est ce alors que me faire d'études
littéraires on veut faire hypokhâgne ont
fait l savant ce n'avait aucune logique
et aujourd'hui donc on va proposer aux
élèves dès la seconde de réfléchir à
leur orientation et de choisir dès la
première des spécialités qui auront des
volumes horaires qui leur permettra de
vous re qui leur permettront de vraiment
acquérir les bases dans ses
enseignements et être sûr d'avoir un
niveau nécessaire insuffisant pour
pouvoir suivre universités d'accord mais
à ce moment là ce que justement il n'y a
plus le droit à l'erreur c'est à dire
que peut-être que
1 essai 1 va accepter le choix de ses
parents puis ensuite et qui joue aussi
sa spécialité donc même si un petit peu
poussé par les parents pourquoi pas il a
quand même deux autres spécialités qui
donc c'est plus facile de faire trois
choix que d'en faire un seul donc en
faisant deux ou trois
le choix de ces trois spécialités il a
droit à l'erreur puisque on termine à
une en gardera que deux donc il pourra
éliminer une de ses spécialités
et tout ça en but après donc après le
post bac de choisir un
direction donc pour ses études
supérieures est l'objectif de cette
réforme est de d'être plus en adéquation
avec l'orientation post bac et de
satisfaire des professeurs d'université
qui aujourd'hui se plaignent certains
élèves n'ont pas le niveau requis pour
pouvoir suivre les enseignements à
l'université on se plonge aujourd'hui
que 40 % simplement d'une tranche d'âge
arrive à voir sa licence donc à
l'université donc par cette préparation
sur deux années sur des spécialités use
auront quatre heures d'enseignement donc
de spécialité en première et six heures
en terminale cela rajoute un nombre
d'heures donc dans ces matières de
spécialités qui aideront les lèvres
après dans son enseignement sur pause
dans une réaction plusieurs alors là où
nous rejoignons je crois c'est
effectivement sur le caractère
problématique de la filière scientifique
qui dans un premier temps était devenu
est quelque part une filières élitistes
inquiéter celle choisi massivement par
les élèves
et paradoxalement il ya également une
crise des vocations scientifiques à
l'université
donc là il y avait un vrai paradoxe il
ya effectivement un problème auquel il
fallait s attacher mais nous ce que nous
observons justement dans ce qui est
proposé par la réforme bancaire
c'est que cette réforme s'accompagne
d'une diminution des horaires qui va
entraîner aussi un certain nombre de
diminutions de postes
sans doute une réponse à la pénurie
d'enseignants mathématique puisque si on
supprime des postes on aura moins de
problèmes pour trouver des profs est par
exemple si on prend le cas des
enseignements que vont pouvoir choisir
les élèves puisque à terre mais ils en
choisissent plus que deux en terminale
il va devenir impossible pour un élève
qui souhaitent étudier les sciences
d'étudier à la fois la physique chimie
les mathématiques et des svt puisqu'il
doit choisir maintenant deux
enseignements parmi ces 3 est donc là où
ça va évidemment poser problème aussi
c'est lorsque ces élèves qui peut être
on fait des choix moins bien informés
vous découvrir en classe de terminale au
moment où il faudra en perdra consupe
qu'avant suivi l'enseignement de
mathématiques faisait partie d'un des
attendus de l'université dans lesquels
dans laquelle il souhaitait aller et que
direction spécialité mais il ya
également une option est donc l'option
permet de faire encore une troisième
matière donc l'élève peut très bien
choisir mathématiques en option
si on se fie zidane option donc il peut
quand même compléter ce choix par une
option qui n'est pas obligatoire mais
qui est possible il est l'option
permettra justement de rattraper le gap
le fait qu'en première par exemple n'est
pas pensée de prendre une spécialité
mathématiques est ce que le terminal
justement il veut s'inscrire dans un
cursus d'informatique on lui dit qu'il
n'a pas fait se lever le matin est ce
que l'option permettra de rattraper
notamment sa terreur alors y aura une
possibilité de démarrer dans certains
cas donc un enseignement à condition
d'avoir créé un niveau correct moyens
dans dans la matière et puis d'accepter
de faire comme on le voit sur des
parcours personnalisés donc au niveau de
l'université de faire des travaux
complémentaires pendant l'été pour
l'élève qui souhaiteraient démarrer une
nouvelle spécialité en alternance mais
travaux complémentaires c'est au sein de
l'éducation nationale ce sera ce sera
sûrement d une partie de devoir un
travail personnel de l'élève puisse plus
peut-être une semaine de pré rentrée
pour pouvoir se mettre à niveau d'accord
au sein de l'ue du lycée qui n'est pas
d'accord alors que la question des maths
il ya un cas de figure par exemple qui
va certainement être problématique c'est
le cas l'élève qui suit l'enseignement
de mathématiques et qui va vouloir
suivre l'option supplémentaire de
mathématiques approfondie celui ci il ne
pourra pas faire il va faire des matchs
des maths approfondie puis d'svt la
physique mais il devra choisir
donc il ya un réel problème là dessus je
voudrais rebondir aussi sur ce qui a été
dit sur la réussite des élèves à
l'université puisque c'est vrai qu'on
constate y avait des taux d'échec est
relativement élevé en deux premières
années mais nous ce qu'on sait aussi
c'est que il y à 80 % des élèves qui en
quatre ans réussit à obtenir un diplôme
de niveau bac plus 3 mais 4 ans ça veut
dire que peut-être certains élèves sont
d'échec en première année se réoriente
se trompent
évidemment il ce que nous nous défendons
au snes et la fsu et la fédération
syndicale dont je fais partie c'est le
droit de chaque étudiant à rentrer à
l'université et avoir le droit de se
tromper et style est prévue avec le
lycée blanc caire c'est justement l'idée
que l'élève à faire des choix qui dès la
fin de la seconde vont l'orienter évolué
formé à un certain nombre de portes on
souhaiterait qu'il lui reste ouverte
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a
et montrer que pour l'entrée universités
les portes sont fermées à personne et
quels que soient les choix qu'ils auront
été faits au lycée il y aura toujours
possibilité de faire justement sa
licence en quatre ans si l'élève a fait
des choix totalement erronée on va dire
jusqu'au baccalauréat ils souhaitent
s'orienter dans une nouvelle matière il
pourra toujours faire une licence en
quatre ans pour pouvoir justement se
mettre à niveau sur des matières qui
aurait fait ce qui aujourd'hui
correspond à un grande partie de la
réalité
alors mes statistiques disent pas tout à
fait 80 % en quatre ans je suis plus
près des 70 ou même en dessous des 70
pour pour en quatre ans mais mais c'est
vrai que là réussie de la licence en
trois ans donc et à 40% et en quatre
hommes
on est même en dessous des 80 mais
encore justement ce nouveau bac va
permettre aux lycéens d'être mieux
préparés notamment pour l'orientation et
puis on sait pourquoi pas pour un avenir
professionnel beaucoup plus concret mais
l'accompagnement sur l'orientation qui
va démarrer dès la classe de seconde
donc avec une heure et demie
hebdomadaire donc d'orientation qui
représente 54 heures annuelles pour
pouvoir faire son choix d'orientation va
permettre à l'élève donc et nous leur
faisons confiance
2-2 de prendre une direction qui en
toute logique dans 80 % de cas des
élèves seront cohérentes avec avec leurs
études supérieures et et dans ce cas là
ils auront en finale plus de ce qu'on
propose aujourd'hui c'est de faire plus
d'heures sur un plus petit nombre
d'élèves réellement souhaité en faire
ces matières là plutôt que de donner par
exemple des mathématiques à 50 % des
élèves qui a pris et on faire du droit
ou de psycho ou des choses comme ça
aujourd'hui on a un très gros nombre
d'élèves
duby suivent un programme très élevé de
mathématiques en section scientifique et
qui ne les exploite pas du tout après en
à l'université aujourd'hui donc ils
seront peut-être moins nombreux à
prendre ces options ils auront plus
d'heures d'accord on arrive à la fin de
cette émission déjà
est ce que pour vous il ya d'autres
choses qui vous dérange notamment dans
cette réforme du pack du baquet alors là
alors il ya la question de la seconde
dont on a peu parlé puisqu'on était
plutôt orientée vers le bac mais sur la
question des heures les seconds dont
seront seront à 26 eur en fait comme au
collège et toute une série
d'enseignements qui venait en plus des
enseignements disciplinaires de
l'accompagnement personnalisé des
enseignements d'exploration
tout ceci va disparaître puisque ne sera
plus en plus d'inclure dans les joueurs
disciplinaire des élèves et seront
financés seront les besoins
d'accord je suis surprise que vous
n'ayez pas parler de la vraie réforme du
baccalauréat en tant qu examen puisque
en fin de compte donc il ya une réforme
aussi en terme d'épreuves
donc il y aura une partie le contrôle
continu il y aura beaucoup moins
d'épreuves finale au baccalauréat
donc certaines qui se passeront donc
avant les vacances de printemps 2 deux
épreuves avant les vacances printemps et
simplement deux épreuves au mois de juin
contrairement à l'heure actuelle où
certains élèves ont confirmé brian
d'épreuves allégé plus facile et moins
cher notamment un seul non ce n'est pas
une question de coût c'est simplement
une question de pouvoir également
évaluer les élèves un petit peu plus tôt
dans l'année pour que ces notes d'examen
final soit pris en compte dans leur
orientation post-bac très bien toute
petite conclusion non cela déjà la fin
de cette émission merci à vous d'avoir
participé quant à vous je vous invite à
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet et josh sole de passer une
agréable soirée à la semaine prochaine
merci
[Musique]